kate you do sound quite adventurous uh
what was the there was a was it a
swimming thing or a s or a boating thing
you took your kids on in australia
oh
no no i had this moment where we we went
to this waterhole that was called rose's
hole roses well that's said the actress
to the bishop
listen where is this place
you can't see it anyway
rose's hole
and um i love australia and we were
swimming for two hours and i suddenly
thought you know the kids were in there
i thought i should probably ask are
there any crocodiles here and they went
no no crocodiles so we swam for two
hours and we were you know we're sunning
ourselves on the rocks afterwards and he
said so why is it called rose's
waterhole
and they said oh because you know once
rose is now 80 years old found herself
stunning here and there was a um an
alligator beside
her i went so where did the alligator
come from oh they're in the water
and so they thought i was concerned
about crocodiles but i would be fine
with my three children swimming with
alligators and went no no actually no
yeah it was that's the way it is
[Music]